you see this is why failure is more
important than success because if that
mummy reboot had succeeded it launched
the dark universe as it was intended to
we probably never would have gotten to
see what would happen if Nick Cage and
all Nick cages went Splat with Count
Dracula
[Music]
so renfield's directed by Chris McKay
Stars Nicholas Holt as Renfield who is
Dracula's familiar Nicholas Cage plays
Count Dracula and this movie is a bloody
dark comedy slash allegory about getting
out of toxic relationships with
narcissists okay obviously we're dealing
with a little bit more than just
narcissism here and half of this movie
is exactly what the trailer pitches and
promises you which is exactly what works
Renfield and Dracula that whole dynamic
it's pretty awesome when I heard
Nicholas Cage was playing Dracula in
this movie before I saw the trailer I
was like that that's one of those calls
either someone knows exactly what
they're doing or they are so far off the
mark happy to say it absolutely works it
works for the tone of that I mean it
wouldn't work for any movie if you
plopped Nicholas Cage Dracula in Bram
Stoker's Dracula no but for a hyper
violent bloody dark comedy in which
Nicholas Cage can just be unhinged and
be that which we know to be Nick Cage
also Dracula version of him it totally
works as we all know there's only only
one Nick Cage and so this is the only
person who can ever play Dracula like
this and actually have it work the big
bummer is the unbearable weight of
massive Talent came out last year if it
had come out after this movie came out
they'd have a lot more to play with
Nicholas Holtz also great in this movie
I feel like in these past years we've
seen Nicholas Holtz either get better at
his comedic timing or get roles in which
he can better articulate it and show it
on screen it also has a bit of a
superhero angle in there he eats bugs
that's how he gets the powers that
Dracula's giving him in which case he
can completely annihilate people by
annihilate them I mean punch their heads
off rip their arms off I was baffled
every now and then when ass and blood
just shoots everywhere and it's like a
couple drops just hit the person that
did it or the person that's two feet
from the body that exploded and it was
like the CGI blood has to become real
blood on the people for the next shot
you know like I knew he forgot something
there is something amazing about blood
and gore that goes together with comedy
so well I won't say like peanut butter
and jelly it's not that commonplace but
definitely peanut butter and honey it's
that delicious the action sequences they
were great exciting bloody fun
absolutely and I feel like the allegory
the relationship between Renfield and
Dracula and Renfield trying to break
away but Dracula being a narcissist
that's what's gonna hit people if they
get hooked with this movie that's the
hook it's actually really well done with
characters that are perfect allegory for
that that said that's half the movie
there's another movie wrapped into this
movie that makes you go like where did
this come from no one no one cares and
it has to deal with aquafina's character
playing this cop in this Precinct
they're corrupt cops and she's trying to
take down this mob family I'm telling
you it feels like someone was like yeah
I'm working on a script right now for a
movie I call Renfield we're trying to
get Nick Cage to play Dracula don't
worry it should work it'll be a violent
dark comedy slash allegory about toxic
relationships I'll have superhero
elements you know Renfield will eat bugs
he'll get powers and totally obliterate
Baddies I only have 45 minutes of script
written now so
don't quite know what to do with it that
sounds amazing to me let me know how
that goes I'm working on a script right
now too we're trying to get Aquafina for
the role she's this nice cop in a
Precinct full of crooked cops she
doesn't know who to trust her father was
killed on duty by these Mobsters so
she's trying to take down these Mobsters
who deal Coke don't have a title yet but
I call it Coke decks
you know dick d-i-c-s as in detectives
in charge and it's a working title
anyway but I only have 45 minutes of the
script written so I don't know what to
do with it either wait a minute I have
45 minutes I have 45 minutes by the
power of math we combine these two into
one 90-minute film boom it feels like
that is exactly what happened this movie
feels like two movies and one of these
movies is really compelling the other
one probably could have been as its own
movie in a Renfield Dracula movie just
feels out of place granted in any
vampire or Dracula movie you're gonna
have people that aren't Supernatural and
they're just kind of peering into this
situation as to what's going on I get
Renfield getting a friend absolutely but
to bring the precinct and these Mobsters
into the story in that Renfield kind of
feels like the Warcraft movie for me
where I'm like half of that movie was
great the other half I did not care
about only instead of the great half
being the Orcs it's the Dracula Renfield
element in the end when this movie was a
bloody good time it was when it was
funny the audience was laughing Nicolas
Cage and Nicholas halt have an amazing
Dynamic and if anyone buys a ticket just
to see Nick Cage play Dracula the way he
does I would not fault them the movie
started out amazing but as it kept going
felt the momentum just got compromised
with this other movie within the movie
that I just didn't care about I feel
like this movie be a better time with a
bit of the sacrament yes now it's a
party all right so Renfield have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
boom
[__] I gotta pick those up for the next
shot